[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lors du 7-8 journal sur
tv 78 nous sommes le mardi et 14
novembre
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
locale et dix villes des yvelines sont
équipés par le système d'autopartage le
service autolib fait l'objet de
nombreuses critiques dans le département
et les communes concernées s'inquiète
des déficits de l'équipement géré par le
groupe bolloré chronique dans ce journal
c'est la semaine des écrivains
persécutés emprisonnés empêché à cette
occasion poète et auteur vont à la
rencontre des jeunes saint quentinois et
demain une soirée spéciale soutien aux
prix ce mail en cours nous en parlons
avec jacques fournier et directeur d
itinéraire poétique et rémy ngono
journalistes camerounais exilés
aujourd'hui en france enfin comme chaque
mardi le portrait de la rédaction
consacrer une personnalité minois ce
soir nous partons à la rencontre de marc
bourgne le rambolitains 1 c'est à
imaginer dessina des aventures depuis 23
ans et dont la plus célèbre michel
vaillant avant de développer ces titres
il interpelle
emmanuel macron au sujet de la ligne 18
plusieurs élus locaux concernés par le
dossier ont envoyé une lettre au
président de la république
parmi les signataires les agglomérations
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de
versailles grand parc
dans ce courrier rappelé l'importance du
maintien du projet qui doit relier
versailles à l'aéroport d'orly
primordial pour l'attractivité du
territoire et en vue des jeux olympiques
2024 elle le gouvernement doit faire
prochainement des annonces sur la ligne
dans un contexte de rumeurs d'abandon du
tracé ou de report du calendrier avec
moi au plateau arthur kenigsberg bonsoir
vous êtes le responsable du pôle
formation des jeunes avec mâcon 78 alors
vous êtes venu à nous parler de la
grande marche déjà mme s'est testé en ce
moment ça va être testé dans les
yvelines on va voir ça dans un instant
petite réaction peut-être sur
l'actualité politique du jour une
centaine d'adhérents de la république en
marche va quitter le mouvement ce sont
de simples adhérents mais aussi des élus
animateurs de comités locaux dans une
tribune il
11 le manque de démocratie au sein de la
république en marche
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire vous savez
georges clemenceau avait cette formule
georges clemenceau dont on parle
beaucoup à ces derniers temps avec cette
formule échoué c'est abandonner avant
d'avoir réussi et je pense que pour
imposer la démocratie chez en marche il
fallait rester dans le mouvement car on
change les choses de l'intérieur et non
de l'extérieur et si notre parti ne
marchait pas à l'heure actuelle s'il n'y
avait pas de véritable démocratie alors
je ne saurais expliquer pourquoi 166
mille adhérents supplémentaires se sont
joints au mouvement depuis l'élection d'
emmanuel macron pas de recul du
mouvement du coup nous calons vaud aucun
alors vous êtes venus pour cette
actualité parlé d'une action lancée dans
les yvelines c'est la grande marche des
âges âme
quel est le principe de cette grande
marche alors le principe c'est de
s'inspirer véritablement de la grande
marche qui avait lancé manuel macron
lorsqu'il a lancé le mouvement en marche
aie aie aie aie dans toute la france
c'est ça allait dans toute la france
poser des questions et essayer de
convaincre des gens les convaincre aussi
d'aller voter alors nous la démarche est
un peu différente et notre philosophie
aussi c'est à dire que nous on va se
concentrer principalement sur les
quartiers populaires et les territoires
ruraux et du coup seulement sur le
département des yvelines
pour l'instant c'est testée jusqu'au 16
décembre dans les yvelines
on a jusqu'au 16 décembre pour rendre
une synthèse de nos travaux et ensuite
le national évaluera notre synthèse et
ce projet pourrait faire l'objet d' être
étendue au niveau national et donc
d'aller partout en france à la rencontre
des citoyens des quartiers populaires et
aider et des zones rurales
c'est ça c'est une initiative finalement
des jeunes ipad pour y est c'est
complètement une initiative a été
validée par le bureau national et la
série tester juste sur les événements et
peut-être de l'étendre au niveau
national pourquoi il est important selon
vous de se rendre sur place pour faire
un diagnostic directement parce que vous
savez après les élections généralement
les partis politiques se démobilisent et
nous justement nous voulons continuer à
aller sur le terrain
continuer à aller là où les partis
politiques ne vont pas or élections
c'est à dire que nous voulons être un
véritable thermomètre aussi pour le
président de la république et pour le
mouvement pour faire remonter la
température de ce qui se passe dans ce
qu'on appelle les endroits perdus de la
république vous avez ciblé justement des
on a six mois commence dès vendredi à
trappes
j'ai vu tout à l'heure dans un article
que tu rappes était le bastion de la
république des djihadistes et bien nous
voulons aller à trappes dans ces
quartiers difficiles parler avec les
gens il ne s'agit en aucun cas de les
convaincre
seulement de les écouter parce que ces
gens là ont des choses à nous dire ils
font face à des réalités que nous
pouvons mal connaître ou méconnaître et
nous avons la modestie est également l'
envie d'aller vers ces gens et des
rencontres sur place tout ça ça va
servir à quoi ensuite alors ensuite on a
des questionnaires on va poser quelques
questions et ensuite ces questionnaires
on va retravailler dessus et on en fera
à toute une synthèse et cette synthèse
si elle s'étend au niveau national sera
envoyée au président de la république
directement derrière choisi nous reste
20 secondes une opération réussie c'est
ça c'est que ce soit ensuite étendu au
niveau national ou une opération réussie
à mon avis pour véritablement peser sur
la politique française il faut que ce
soit étendue au niveau national merci
arthur kenigsberg je le rappelle vous
êtes le responsable du pôle formation
des jeunes avec macron 78 dans les
yvelines elle dans l'actualité également
un nouveau laboratoire pour l'université
versailles à saint quentin en yvelines
les chercheurs en physique l'ont
inauguré hier au bâtiment fermât à
versailles
c'est un espace consacré à l'étude de la
matière et dont les outils sont
particulièrement à la pointe
marylène iapichino depuis six ans déjà
le bâtiment des sciences de l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
accueille un groupe de recherche en
physique bien pointues le groupe d'étude
de la matière condensée gmac
c'est la recherche fondamentale c'est
pour comprendre la physique de la base
pour après manipuler les matériaux pour
des applications spécifiques
c'est pour ça qu'il ya un breton
maintenant que tous les équipements sont
pleinement opérationnelles
l'université a réuni hier des
scientifiques concernés par ces
recherches pour inaugurer son
laboratoire aux outils ultra
perfectionnés en fait ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le laboratoire était à
l'origine sur deux sites
un site qui étaient ici sur l'université
de versailles à un site qui était à
meudon et donc ces deux ces deux sites
ont été regroupés en un laboratoire ici
donc il ya eu de nouveaux locaux et
toutes les expériences ont été
regroupées ici sur le site de versailles
ils sont 34 permanent aux blouses
blanches à faire de la recherche ici des
machines impressionnantes comme celle ci
pour recréer des diamants ou celle ci
dont il n'existe qu'un seul autre
exemplaire en france disponible à la
recherche 1600 m² de locaux investis par
les cinq équipes de recherche est ouvert
aux étudiants les plus curieux dont vous
voyez on est au milieu de l'université
c'est à dire qu'il ya des ans filles des
étudiants qui circulent autour du
laboratoire régulièrement donc il ya une
très forte interaction entre eux les
chercheurs du laboratoire et les
étudiants de l'université
créée en 1991 l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin compte dix-huit
mille étudiants répartis sur cinq campus
avec moi sur ce plateau nicolas
kirillovitch bonsoir bonsoir la
rédaction tv 70 on va se poser avec vous
une question est ce que c'est le début
d'un divorce entre les yvelines et
autolib le système d'autopartage est la
cible de nombreuses critiques est depuis
plusieurs mois dans le département les
collectivités qui proposent le service
s'inquiète notamment du déficit de cet
équipement géré par le groupe bolloré
alors ces collectivités ont décidé
nicolas de se faire entendre
en effet et pour bien comprendre l'enjeu
du problème commençons par un chiffre
celui qui va s'afficher sur l'écran 179
millions d'euros ce n'est pas le chiffre
d'affaires est généré par le service
autolib' met son déficit prévu à
l'horizon 2
ils 23 selon des informations du groupe
bolloré vous le disais qu'ils gèrent
autolib depuis 2011
et c'est se chiffre précisément qui a
semé le trouble auprès des collectivités
territoriales du département puisque le
groupe bolloré s'engage à payer
seulement une partie de cette dette 60
millions d'euros
il resterait alors à la charge des
villes adhérentes 119 millions d'euros à
régler et selon des informations parues
dans la presse resam récemment en fait
ce déficit pourrait même atteindre 250
millions d'euros ce qui rajoute
évidemment de l'inquiétude à
l'inquiétude est d'ailleurs nicolas ce
déficit pousse les communes à réfléchir
sur leur investissement
oui depuis un an maintenant beaucoup
d'entre elles font marche arrière la
ville de bois d'arcy par exemple a
décidé de ne plus installer du tout deux
stations sur son territoire alors que la
première devait être inaugurée à cette
année la ville de versailles elle
ralentit les investissements
neuf stations sont prévues initialement
à elle se limite à 5 pour le moment et
l'agglomération de 50 ans divine et est
aussi concernée elle a décidé de stopper
les installations pour l'instant à la
base 26 stations sont prévues sur le
territoire tout est prêt selon les
services de l'agglomération
mais rien n'est déployée au regard
justement des risques financiers
fermez les guillemets un constat négatif
est ce qu'il est possible pour autolib
d'inverser cette tendance
eh bien oui selon les élus yvelinois
justement et notamment philippe
brillault le maire l'est républicain de
la ville du chesnay qui a pris en
quelque sorte la fronde 1 de 7 de la
faune locale sa ville était la première
initialement à avoir installé autolib
dans les yvelines
et il demande une réorganisation de la
stratégie d'autolib
pour lui il faut davantage communiquer
pour attirer plus d'utilisateurs arrêté
aussi la chasse à la voiture lancée par
la mairie de paris selon un philippe
brillault et valoriser aussi le service
autolib face à la concurrence des vtc ou
des taxis et surtout philippe brillault
souhaite plus de transparence pour
connaître les vrais problèmes
d'autolib un petit exemple un autre site
a été lancé il ya neuf mois
les résultats ne sont toujours pas
connues alors selon philippe brillault
il en va de la survie d'autolib écoutez
le la direction d'origine tel qu'il a
été prévu de la délégation initial qui
n'était faite que pour la ville de paris
ne va plus dans le bon sens et donc
comme toutes nouvelles choses mais il
faut la réactualiser c'est ce que je
demande c'est ce que nous demandons et
je suis bien déterminé à mobiliser
l'ensemble des communes qui partagent
mon point de vue sur le sujet voire même
des élus de paris qui devront se
réveiller s'interroger et se mobiliser
je dis qu'aujourd'hui c'est une urgence
et en tant que médecin je sais que les
urgences sont importantes sinon elles
ont des conséquences létale et grégory
une mauvaise nouvelle n'arrive jamais
seule pour la première fois en l'espace
de cinq ans les abonnements autolib sont
en baisse entre 2017 et 2016 - 5 % pour
atteindre aujourd'hui un peu plus de 103
mille abonnements actifs
merci nicolas pour ces précisions santé
aujourd'hui c'est la journée mondiale du
diabète elle sert à informer
sensibiliser à cette maladie qui touche
qui touche plusieurs personnes dont
beaucoup de personnes parfois sans
qu'elle le sache
on estime en france que sept cent mille
français ignorent être diabétique il est
donc important de se faire dépister tout
le mois de novembre des pharmacies
participent à une opération gratuite et
anonyme
un sujet de camille lambert va saigner
voilà je vais vous poser quelques
questions justes tout commence par un
petit questionnaire taille poids
antécédents et régime alimentaire
autant d'éléments qui permettent de
déterminer le risque d'être diabétique
place ensuite aux tests à l'aide d'un
glucomètre l'appareil permet de mesurer
le taux de glucose dans le sang en
dessous de à g 10 si on n'a pas eu de
repas à moins de deux heures
la certitude il qu'il y a sept cent
mille personnes qui sont diabétiques et
qu'ils l'ignorent parce que c'est une
maladie soudaine perte de vue infections
les symptômes n'apparaissent réel manque
un stade avancé de la maladie lui rps
mène donc depuis trois ans une campagne
de dépistage du diabète en ile de france
cette année le groupement de pharmaciens
pharma vie a permis d'élargir cette
opération à toute la france
on est à un petit peu plus de 1000
personnes qui ont été en tout cas
dépistés et sur les 1000 il ya une
soixantaine de personnes qui ont une
semie sub normal et qui ont été donc
adressée auprès du médecin le diabète et
c'est une cause nationale donc l'idée
étant de de sensibiliser les personnes
partout en france et donc nous avons
incité l'ensemble du réseau a participé
à ces journées et donc nous avons à
l'heure actuelle plus de 100 tomassi qui
participent à ces défis stage
plus de deux millions et demi de
français sont atteints de diabète
parmi les personnes à risque celle de
plus de 45 ans celle en surpoids ayant
un diabétique dans la famille ou les
femmes ayant eu du diabète lors d'une
grossesse dans les yvelines il est
possible de se faire dépister à
guyancourt où dans rambouillet jusqu'au
30 novembre
autre journée mondiale c'est demain
celle des écrivains en prison toute
cette semaine est en fait consacrée à
ces auteurs persécutés empêcher
emprisonné au seul motif de leur écrit
et on accueille sur ce plateau pour en
parler
deux invités jacques fournier bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur d
itinéraire poétique de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et nous avons
également rémy ngono avec nos bons soirs
bon ce journaliste camerounais vous êtes
exilé en france depuis 13 ans de 12 ans
environ maintenant alors on va on va
voir ensemble demain cette soirée c'est
une soirée consacrée ces écrivains
persécutés juste avant ça je vous
propose de regarder ce sujet hier les
élèves du lycée de villa roi à
guyancourt ont pu rencontrer un
journaliste camerounais vous à rémy
ngono est un poète siro kurdes une
rencontre proposée par les itinéraires
politique de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
reportage de mélanie poquet et marie
pannetrat dans une saison us témoignages
poignants mots durs discours plein
d'émotion
les écrivains persécutés racontent leur
histoire les élèves de seconde et de
première du lycée de villeroy à
guyancourt sont attentifs et prennent
des notes
c'est une expérience quand même que nous
on pourra pas vivre et qu'on veut un
convive rationnement pas donc ils nous
ont apporté leur expérience personnelle
ému les élèves découvrent le vécu de
rémy ngono journalistes camerounais
persécuté pour avoir dénoncé la
corruption dans son pays
et de gaulle à nagy un poète cure de
syriens témoin de la persécution en
syrie j'ai été émue par la persévérance
des écrivains et tout
genre ils sont persécutés mais il
continue pas mais je trouve ça ça
vraiment beau une rencontre riche non
seulement pour les élèves mais aussi
pour les écrivains pour moi je suis
curieux de savoir des ces avis les de
ces générations un jeu je discute ces
idées avec le public jeune
je me trouve à quelques fois comme des
surprises parce que je pendant 7
change je me trouve des dans un autre
endroit de pour penser de ces idées très
important dans notre époque avec moi sur
ce plateau je le rappelle de personnes
que l'on a vu dans ce sujet rémy ngono
qui est journaliste camerounais exilé en
france depuis 12 ans environ est
également jacques fournier qui est le
directeur est 10 itinéraire poétique de
saint quentin en yvelines alors demain
est organisée la septième soirée des
écrivains à persécuter
c'est au prix smile en cours à partir de
20 heures un événement exceptionnel dont
on parle dans un instant on l'a dit
jacques une semaine consacrée sur saint
quentin en yvelines à ces écrivains
persécutés emprisonnés et empêcher on le
voit dans ce reportage
il ya une importance de cette rencontre
les jeunes ont apprécié de pouvoir
rencontrer ses auteurs oui parce que dès
qu'on a lancé cette action avec mes
collègues de la ex maison la poésie
maintenant étaient apolitiques sur le
territoire on a tout de suite envisagée
ses rencontres avec des collégiens de 3e
des lycéens et des étudiants fait que
cette semaine par exemple on va faire
nos quatre invités vous rencontrez 650
jeunes et c'est une chouette s'est
laissé des traces et les traces on l'est
on les voit on sur place sur le moment
même leur réaction lors leur silence
aussi le regard parfois gênés devant ces
quelques moments racontée par nos
invités parce que c'est pas toujours
facile à vivre
les échanges aussi les retours qu'on
peut avoir et c'est essentiel parce que
c'est eux qui vont construire le monde
de demain il faut il faut qu'il fasse en
sorte que le monde de demain soit
meilleur que celui d'aujourd'hui et on
le fait en rapportant la parole de ces
gens qui ont choisi de dire non à
l'obscurantisme à la au totalitarisme et
il faut qu'ils soient vigilants
2 par rapport à tout ce qui se passe
dans le monde actuellement et réunion on
parle de votre histoire dans un instant
et témoigner auprès des jeunes c'était
quelque chose d'important pour vous très
important dans la mesure où la jeunesse
quoi qu'on dise c'est l'avenir de demain
et on ne peut pas vivre avec le passé
faut plutôt jardinot futur les
expériences que nous vivons constitue
pour eux aussi seront pas appelés à une
prix des détresses faut qu'ils sachent
que parfois dans certains pays qui sont
encore plongé dans le totalitarisme dans
l'obscurantisme qu' il ya des individus
qui ont besoin de cette liberté et eu
parfois dans certaines chaînes de télé
ils n'ont pas la possibilité de voir
toutes ces choses là parce qu'ils
prennent cela comme si c'était une mise
en scène comme si c'était des histoires
illusoire comme c'était totalement du
cinéma et lorsqu'il se retrouve devant
moi ils sont totalement choqués
abasourdis que à cette époque qu'on
puisse encore vivre des scènes aussi
délirante et qu'on puisse empêcher à
l'être humain d'exercer l'audois le plus
universel à savoir la liberté
l'exposition a justement votre liberté
d'expression vous interdis de l'exercer
au cameroun votre histoire personnelle
vous avez quitté le cameroun en 2005
j'ai subi des pressions vous avez même
été contraint à ne plus exercer votre
métier pendant six mois vous avez été
emprisonnés condamnés pour rappel à la
rebellion commentaires tendancieux et
outrage au chef de l'état paul biya est
en fait tout ça pour avoir dit dans une
émission satirique des choses pour avoir
condamné certaines choses qu'il fallait
mettre en avant justement parce que d'un
régime dictatorial il faut savoir que la
parole ou l'écriture est synonyme d'une
aux banques parce que l'émotion plus
fort voilà voilà justement parce que
pour eux
un coutelas on sait pas blessé mais à
montcuq en dictature donc justement
parce que je me suis retrouvé dans un
régime beaucoup sanguinaire régime de
l'opposition faut-il le dire le cameroun
n'a connu que deux chefs des cas et
c'est deux chefs d'état harthouse et ils
n'ont jamais pratiqué les métaux de
qu'on peut parler de démocratique et moi
et en constater que ça ne fonctionnait
pas j'ai donc créé une émission qu'on
appelait le congrès chaud et là il y
avait juste une rubrique on appelle l
eau profonde
le fait de pouvoir dire stop à la
corruption
stop au népotisme stop à se compacter
les la maltraitance les détournements
que tout cela justement parce que le
poisson pourrit par la tête
le régime s'est sentie totalement
attaquer et bien sûr quand le régime ait
attaqué je deviens à ce qu'on peut
appeler une tumeur cancérigène qui font
tout de suite à minuit les écrans subi
des pressions justement on vous pousse à
arrêter votre métier vous avez été
contraint d'arrêter votre métier sur
place ça donne encore plus envie de
témoigner c'est vous et vous n'êtes pas
eu du tout doute à ce moment là il faut
savoir que les explosions mais surtout
nous qui sommes pour qui n'avons qu'un
seul instrument de travail la parole
nous sommes comme les permis les opm
peuvent étouffer la perdrix mais ne
peuvent pas étouffer ses cris
donc plus on a voulu m'étouffer
plusieurs voulu crier plus fort donc
chaque fois avant que je mets en prison
j'ai quand même été arrêté quatorze fois
et quand on dit arrêté quatorze fois
c'est comme si on venait prendre le plus
grand talibans du monde le plus grand
terroriste ayant des bombes et bien sûr
que c'est l'armée qui vient avec la
police pour non seulement me ridiculiser
devant mes collaborateurs la nuit des
temps voilà
si j'étais limité d'états avant d'aller
dans une prison qu'on appelle quand même
le kosovo imaginer nous sommes au
cameroun et on appelle une prison le
kosovo c'est à dire que j'étais dans mon
lit les cellules comme je le dis de 4
mètres sur 5 pour 47 personnes et
j'étais la 48e personnes à dormir à même
le sol et donc vous êtes en france
depuis 2005 il ne reste déjà une minute
dans cet entretien dont il faudrait bien
sûr plus de temps votre histoire est
assez riche pour voilà pour en parler
mais jacques fournier peut-être un mot
sur la soirée de demain cette soirée des
écrivains emprisonnés empêcher et
persécuté persécutés j'avais pu le mot
et rémy ngono sera au ricoh tel
rayonnement pour ela sera aux côtés
d'autres écrivains qu'on avait invité à
la mohammad poète et cinéaste syrienne
je la magie hussein que vous avez vu
dans le film qui est kurdes de syrie et
tel shahriari un dramaturge et poète
iranien et ils seront accompagnés d'une
jeune musicienne très talentueuse qui
s'appelle maïs à djalal jeu de flûte
traversière et toute la soirée sera
animée par catherine pour lambert et
avec laquelle nous collaborons depuis
très longtemps il faut savoir aussi que
cette semaine est possible parce que
nous avons des partenaires c'est la
seule à la maison d éclat maison des
journalistes à paris
et amnesty international qui sera
présente aussi à la soirée ainsi que la
libre et une pavés du canal qui
permettra de présenter quelques livres
de nos invités mais aussi d'autres
écrivains qui connaissent ou ont connu
la persécution dans leur pays et je
remercie de la direction du prisme de
nous accueillir dans son théâtre pour
cette soirée à 20 heures demain soir
c'est déjà la fin de cet entretien le
cas pour plus d'informations vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet d
itinéraire poétique de saint quentin en
yvelines qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci à vous deux jacques fournier rémy
ngono d'abord est avec nous et on vous
retrouve donc demain 6 et 20 heures au
prisme d'elancourt pour cette soirée des
écrivains persécutés
entrée libre entrée libre c'est
important le précisé bercy merci bien
alors c'est notre rendez vous du mardi
le portrait de la rédaction sur une
personnalité yvelinoise lui et
rambolitains depuis 50 ans il imaginait
dessine des aventures qui vous entraîne
dans des mondes de pirates en alaska ou
dans des courses automobiles marquent
bout
scénarisée dessine des bandes dessinées
depuis 23 ans parmi les plus connus
michel vaillant portrait de marie
pannetrat camille lambert et mélanie
poquet la foule devant le château de buc
pour le festival de bande dessinée
plus de 8000 passionné pour rencontrer
notamment marc burg présent chaque année
pour dédicacer les réactions des gens
parce que nous on travaille à chez nous
tout seul c'est un travail très
solitaire ce comme un écrivain par
exemple et donc il ya moyen de d'avoir
des retours avec le public sur sur les
réseaux sociaux les choses comme ça même
si ça fait très peu de temps que j'ai
déçu me suis décidé à mettre sur les
réseaux sociaux
mais bon c'est toujours plus sympa de
voir les gens en vrai c'est ici dans son
atelier à rambouillet que marc bourgne
créer ce jour là il travaille les
planches d'un nouvel album
[Musique]
c'est un one shot c'est ce qu'on appelle
un mois une chose c'est à dire une
histoire complète en un album que
que je dessine sur un scénario d'olivier
berlion et de marques au meilleur est en
fait la collection l'art du crime c'est
une série de one shot d'histoires
complètes qui sont toutes sur le thème
de l'art et du crime
donc je refasse le crayonné à l'encan
alors j'ai des différences kg de
différentes tailles
avant j'utilisais des plumes mais
j'arrive pas à trouver de bonnes plumes
donc j'étais sdd mon stylo et puis une
plume un pinceau et de l'encré de chine
en rambo lite un depuis toujours marc
bourne et dessinateur et scénariste de
bande dessinée depuis 27 ans une
carrière débutée à 23 ans qui a vu
naître une cinquantaine d'albums
l'autodidacte chez autodidacte j'ai fait
des études d'histoire en fait donc j'ai
une maîtrise d'histoire à la sorbonne
mais j'ai fait des études d'histoire
pour avoir un métier le temps de à
savoir prof d'histoire-géo le temps de
réussir à percer dans la bd sauf que
sauf que j'étais enseignant un trimestre
seulement puisque le premier projet que
j'ai envoyée aux éditeurs a été pris
chez dargaud donc c'était ma première
série le premier album c'est celui ci la
grande-terre dessinée écrite en quatre
mois
mais la bd est une vocation découverte à
10 ans le premier album que j'ai lu
c'était le crabe aux pinces d'or
donc c'est pas très original mais bon
c'était là la première bd qui était un
vrai choc c'était
évidemment un album de tintin donc j'ai
été très fans d'hergé je le suis
toujours d'ailleurs
parmi ses inspirations tintin donc mais
aussi alix de jacques martin blueberry
dessiné par jean giraud ou encore le
michel vaillant de jean graton un héros
qu'il dessine aujourd'hui avec 20 jamin
bénéteau 2 puis 6 tomes des planches qui
rappelleront à certains quelques
souvenirs c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal reportage et replay à retrouver
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 excellente
soirée à tous
[Musique]